we can throw some dirt on handshake gate
because everyone involved had a chance
to talk on the record yesterday to clear
this thing up once and for all and you
know richard sherman was caught
red-handed in a lie about baker mayfield
not shaking his hand so we're gonna
start with richard who was on with our
good friend pat mcafee yesterday morning
and sherman was asked if he would
apologize to baker mayfield or if he'd
simply just move on here's sherman from
mcafee's show
it's definitely my bad you know i you
know i never want anybody to have to
deal with that i mean some stuff that
they didn't even do you know and so
you know the the the questions that he's
going to get and the annoying
nonsense questions about um
some stuff that happened in a game
that's already been done you know sure
he'll get an apology for that
hey here's the thing it he calls it
annoying nonsense questions
he made the thing into an issue yeah
it's not annoying or nonsense when he
goes over the top claiming that the guy
snubbed richard sherman when in fact the
indisputable visual evidence tells us
that he didn't and you know chris look
richard sherman had no real options but
to acknowledge that he did it i i still
like the fact that he didn't continue to
push the idea although he did mention he
felt disrespected regardless of what the
interaction was he did acknowledge that
he intends to apologize to baker
mayfield so i got to give him some
credit for that yeah i mean i give him
credit for that too i mean at least yeah
he didn't let this continue to fester
and become an issue and try to make some
bs reason to justify it you know yeah he
he took uh accountability to a degree
for his actions i mean to like your said
oh he was more disappointed in the fact
that now baker is going to have to deal
with the questions okay yeah that you
should apologize for that also
on top of lying that you were not
snubbed and as far as the handshake and
and all that he kind of skirted that
little issue to a degree but either way
uh it was a good start i hope he did
reach out to baker mayfield because it
was a bunch of nonsense totally created
by him
well and baker mayfield was asked after
practice on wednesday whether or not he
had heard from richard sherman here's
what mayfield had to say when he was
asked that question by reporters
i haven't had my phone on me i just got
out of practice but
i just heard that it's nice of him
does he have value at all
when
oh no you know i i know what i did uh
but that's you know the one time
the camera and something recording me is
you know gone in my favor
did you in any way intend to discount
him to be aware no no i respect him who
he is as a player he's a great player
has been for a while
in no way that means like that
baker mayfield takes the high road and
has a little fun with the fact that yeah
he's been caught on camera doing some
stuff that got him in trouble in the
past and this time he's great that's why
he's great yeah you know the camera the
camera never lies and this time around
the camera show that someone else was
lying and you know chris look i i
yeah i
he's brash and sometimes he says things
he shouldn't and he's a work in progress
right we're all a work in progress and
at 22 23 i had a hell of a lot to learn
and i had a hell of a lot to do by way
of maturing and developing and we're
kind of seeing it before our eyes
especially with the young franchise
quarterback these kids are growing up in
a national spotlight and there are going
to be hiccups and there are going to be
problems and there are going to be
issues and i think we need to be willing
to give anyone who's that age who finds
himself thrust into that kind of a
spotlight some sort of a benefit of the
doubt and and i like the fact that baker
mayfield is self-aware he's far more
self-aware quite frankly in his early
20s than richard sherman is in his early
30s well yeah and especially when
richard sherman was in his early 20s
that's not even comparable but that's
what's refreshing about baker mayfield
the fact that he can kind of take a shot
at himself there uh as far as yet the
video comment he is uh you know he
handled himself right there the right
way he took the high road certainly i if
i was baker mayfield and richard sherman
did reach out to me i wouldn't respond
i'm just going to say that i would let
it be at that i would not like try to
like appease richard sherman and let him
think things are all good and cool he
could reach out and apologize and that's
fine and dandy but he's not getting like
oh thanks for reaching out return text
or anything like that no i mean it would
take everything in me to be like no
screw you thanks for this for the last
24 hours of my life to have to deal with
this crap but uh either way uh i listen
baker mayfield he's he's brash that's
the only thing you could say negative
about him maybe he did national
commercials too early on in his career
before he's you know earned the pelts on
the horse as we like to say uh no you
like to say well if that's the only
negative though that's that's a pretty
good thing for 2019 and you made the
point right mike i mean i lived it a
little and i grew up in it and knew what
to expect and still had issues at 23 and
24 with having money in your pocket and
people trying to get at you and all the
different things that go on in the world
it is a little loss of reality certainly
uh when you're when you're in that
situation
see i would take the phone call from
richard sherman i would take the phone
call i would accept the apology i would
be gracious and then at the very end i
would say now richard i'm going to call
mike silver and tell him you never
called me
that's what i would do oh you so you
made me think you were like a a
top-notch you know stand-up guy there
for a second i was like oh that was
really good of you and then you got it
why wouldn't you take but why wouldn't
you want to just put put the hatchet in
this there is a broader brotherhood of
nfl players financially from a health
standpoint
you may be on the same team at some
point okay why wouldn't you want to
change he broke all those rules there's
no rules there he broke the brotherhood
i mean by the bull the you know the bull
crap he tried to peddle to mike silver
and and you know double and triple down
on tweeting so it doesn't matter yeah
maybe they meet each other sometime and
they're on the same team but they'll
deal with it then if i was if i was
baker mayfield yeah i would not respond
i just wouldn't i would be a little
bitter and uh really
you know like i said just annoyed that
it went this far and became an issue and
he tried to paint me in that light
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports